[Music]
this is one of those stories we debated
not doing because it's just so sad it's
just it's just crushingly sad
but in the end we decided we had an
obligation to do it because it's also
true it just happened 13 american
servicemen were killed yesterday in a
bombing outside the kabul airport one of
those servicemen was a u.s marine
called kareem nikui
this video from afghanistan could be the
last taken of him before his death
say hi to the camera say hi
hey
we friends
we friends
friends
friends
yeah
friends
friends
[Music]
ah his father is steve nicoy and he
joins us tonight mr appreciate coming on
and our hearts break for you i'm i mean
that i'm sorry
um i you know it's hard even to know
what to ask you other than
uh to to extend our sincere for real
heartfelt sympathies
um but how are you doing 24 hours later
well i'm going on about 36 hours i
believe that i've been up and um
i'm still in shock
uh the family is devastated
and um his mother who's an excellent mom
um you know is doing the best that she
can
um
considering the circumstances
yeah
so the reason that we wanted to talk to
you i i just to remind everyone of you
watching and people already know this
but that these are real people serving
our country and and dying
uh because they they've been asked to
put their lives um at at risk
so were you concerned your boy is over
there in the final days of our
occupation were you worried for him
oh yeah definitely
he had voiced some worry too to the
family earlier prior to him going
and
um
looked at the
the way that the
taliban had you know pretty much
infiltrated the whole country so fast
and we were just kind of it seemed left
to just this one little airport
really concerned me
and the videos that we were getting in
the pictures that we were getting from
him
looked somewhat chaotic but we got the
video that that you had just played and
we got other ones where he was
really interacting with you know the
locals and
was kind of an on his
approach to
his difficult job so
just
you know that video that you saw in his
pictures and and how he was handling it
really put us at ease
to where we felt like you know he's he's
all right
what's so bitter about this is how
chaotic it was and you know if this had
been handled from bagram air base which
the us controlled for 20 years
it seems like this wouldn't have
happened is that your view
well yeah i mean these are of course my
views and has nothing to do with his
view as a marine and yes you know the
loyalty that he has there i've never
served but yes
my view is
that from what i saw the airport that
they were in it looked like a turkey
shoot
basically it's funneled into like a
single file type entry point at which
you know if you have any sort of
chaos of any of any sort
they would all like gather to that one
funneled area which they would all be
successful and i think that's exactly
what happened
um it was just basically so chaotic and
not not really planned out now i'm a
carpenter and even i could could spot
that
with my untrained military eye
yeah it did seem it did seem pretty
obvious have you heard from the marine
corps the political leadership in this
country since your son's death
yeah they have been incredible so
you know basically what had happened was
how i found out is
i was glued to the tv all day yesterday
because you know we i had woken up and i
i wasn't feeling well
and i just felt like something was wrong
my wife felt that there was something
wrong
and
you know as we go downstairs we realized
that this had happened and now you know
we're we're like well there's some
you know legitimacy to how we're feeling
and you um so we're you know i'm glued
to the tv all day i have my um
and and i see you know it says three
wounded and three killed and ten killed
then 12 then 13
and
you know so many
afghans
and i'm trying to find out what time
this actually took place so i can
reference when he was working
to get some sort of insight
then they said that the president was
gonna talk you know i believe at one
o'clock so i felt like
you know
maybe from that
speech i'd be able to get whether or not
all the families had been um
contacted or if they still have to been
contacted because previously i had i had
seen that you know the the prior
administration would normally contact
people like first like the actual
president of the united states so i had
some sort of sense like hey okay maybe
that would happen so then that's not
happening and things are still
transpiring to be you know a little more
grave and i start googling well how long
does it take for the military to you
know
inform its next of kin and i somehow
from the internet gathered about eight
hours and this is about after he had
talked because after he had talked he
had he had said that you know i believe
he had said that no they're they're
still going to be contacted or i think
maybe the commentator said well there'll
be some knock on the doors tonight so at
that time i didn't know if there was
going to be a knock on the door or a
call so about after his speech
um that he did i then got my phone
and put my phone down by the television
now i had the cable on that had the four
different networks on my cable so i had
fox news bbc
cnn and
something else
which you know i was just the reason i
had that is because i was able to see
you know the optics of the four channels
and
you know pick where i wanted to get my
information from well i also started to
think well you know they're going to
might have possibly come here so what i
had done was i got my phone that has the
camera at the front porch and i put that
down so if anyone was to walk up i'd be
able to rush outside and intercept them
because i didn't i didn't want if
something happened to my son that these
marines nothing against them were to
tell my family i felt like you know that
was my responsibility yeah so
i finally realized you know they're not
gonna come at three o'clock they're
gonna come between five and ten
when everybody's home from work so then
i realized you know okay well you know
five to
if i can make it between five to ten
even if i haven't heard from him i know
that
you know he's all right and he just
doesn't have a way to to contact me
because they either shut down the
internet or shut down cell service or
whatever
and um
7 15
i see something in the corner of my eye
on my phone and three people are walking
up my driveway and my other son his
brother
um had gone to a football game and had
two of his friends so i was hoping that
you know it was him and as soon as i saw
them turn the corner and saw it was
three marine suits my
my life
changed forever
and uh i went down there and met them
and i think i did before they even
knocked on the door and all i kept
saying and and this goes to the point
that you're asking did any service you
know
come and address to us yes
and they were incredible these young men
were so
had so much empathy and were so
concerned
with me and my family who luckily my
family wasn't there it was just me at
the time and i thank god you know i
think jesus that that happened that i
was able to intercept them and all i
kept telling them they were literally
there for like five minutes i was all
you know let's sign whatever papers we
have to sign now but you have to leave
because i have to take care of my family
and i don't want someone to come here
while you're here
and they were totally understanding and
then it dawned on me that yes maybe i
don't need the condolences from them
but i don't want to
i don't want to take that opportunity
from my other family members my wife my
my son
so i asked them look
they're at a football game for the high
school watching a football game can you
please wait down the street
until they come and then i could see if
they want you to come and do your your
your condolences presentation
those marine those boys sat out there
for four hours
for four hours they sat out there
until they came until my wife came which
she
no you know
it was not good and and i could not um
i could not have them come to the house
it was it was horrible like i said i've
been up for about 36 hours but i was i
was in awe and and and
just humbled
by the uh
by their performance
ah
uh i i appreciate steve you're telling
us that
and uh
god bless you
thank you thank you
ah it's just the worst